تقول رئيسة وزراء فنلندا في الخارج
إنها ذهبت إلى حد
إجراء اختبار المخدرات بعد أن أظهر مقطع فيديو مسرب
رقصها واحتفالها مع
أصدقاء رئيس الوزراء أوسانا مارين.
ميليسا بيل من رئيسة الوزراء CNN
تغطي هذه القصة لنا ميليسا نحن
نفهم أن رئيسة الوزراء
تحدثت للتو عن هذه الفضيحة والفضيحة
للكثيرين ولكن يبدو أنها تقلل
من شأنها وتصفها بأنها مسألة خاصة
أه تسميها مسألة خاصة وأنا
أعتقد أنه من الجدير بالذكر أه أليكس أنه
حتى قبل أن يصبح هذا الفيديو علنيًا
وهو ما ندم عليه وسنصل إلى ذلك
في لحظة أه كانت سانتا مارين
موضع اهتمام كبير
لمجرد أنها عندما أصبحت
أصغر رئيسة وزراء في العالم.  في
ذلك الوقت من عام 2019 كانت تبلغ من العمر 34 عامًا وحتى
ذلك الحين برزت في الصور العائلية مع
القادة الآخرين ، وكان الكثير من
مظهرها بالطبع هذا  أحدث مقطع فيديو تم
نشره ينتقل بهذا إلى مستوى جديد تمامًا ، حيث
يمكنك مشاهدة رئيسة الوزراء الفنلندية
في حفلة خاصة وهي ترقص بصوت عالٍ
، وقد أدركت أيضًا أنها
أصدرت بيانًا تقول فيه إنها تشعر
بقوة أن مقاطع الفيديو هذه خاصة
وأنه تم تصويرها فيها  مساحة خاصة
وأنها مستاءة من حقيقة
أنها تم عرضها على الملأ ، كما أشارت
أليكس إلى أنها لم تفعل شيئًا
غير قانوني ، وكان هناك الكثير من التكهنات
عندما ظهر الفيديو لأول مرة أنه
ربما تم تناول المخدرات في
الحفلة كما تفعل  تقول إنها تحدثت الآن
مباشرة إلى ذلك مشيرة إلى أن هذه
كانت عطلة نهاية الأسبوع عندما لم يكن لديها
اجتماعات جادة وكانت تفعل ببساطة ما
سيفعله أي شخص يبلغ من العمر 36 عامًا وهو
الاستمتاع بأوقات مع أصدقائها
لكنها وافقت على إجراء اختبار المخدرات
الذي أعتبره  هذه الاتهامات خطيرة للغاية
، وعلى الرغم من أنني أعتبر الطلب
على اختبار المخدرات غير عادل
لحمايتي القانونية ولتوضيح أي شكوك
أجريتها اليوم لاختبار المخدرات.
ستظهر نتائجه في غضون أسبوع تقريبًا ،
وأضافت سانتا مارين أنها لم تستخدم
المخدرات أبدًا حتى في سنوات المراهقة ،
والسؤال الآن هو مقدار الضرر السياسي الذي تسببه
لها ، هناك حوادث أخرى
يمكننا تذكرها مؤخرًا بوريس
جونسون الذي في النهاية بعد  العديد من التسريبات
حول العديد من الأحزاب التي تتذكر أن أليكس
كانت غير قانونية لأنهم قاموا بإزالتها ،
ودفعوا التكلفة السياسية في النهاية ، لكن الأمر استغرق
وقتًا طويلاً وربما أقرب إلى المنزل ، حيث
ستتذكر أليكساندرا أوكاسيو-كورتيز
عندما دخلت الكونغرس لأول مرة  هذا
الفيديو الذي ظهر
لرقصها وتمكنت من قلبه ضد
منتقديها الآن ، يبدو أن
رئيس الوزراء الفنلندي يسلك طريقًا مشابهًا
قائلاً انظر أنني أفعل
أشياء طبيعية في مثل سني كما أنا ،
وسأستمر في أن أكون ما أنا عليه  وآمل فقط
أن يقبل الناس
أنها تحتفظ في الوقت الحالي
بالدعم الحاسم لحزبها ،
وقد تم التصويت الأسبوع الماضي فقط من قبل إحدى المنشورات الرائدة في ألمانيا.
إنه أروع رئيس وزراء
في العالم قد يكون هناك
انقسام بين الأجيال هنا ولكن هناك أيضًا سؤال
حول امرأة كانت محور
الجدل ليس فقط من أجل الحفلة ولكن
في وقفة لطريقة ارتدائها
وقد يكون العالم كذلك.  لم تكن
معتادًا على رؤية مثل هؤلاء الشابات في السلطة ،
أليكس ، هذا صحيح ، أعني أنها
شوهدت في النوادي التي شوهدت في مهرجان الموسيقى ،
لذا فإن الكثير من الناس يمتدحونها
لعيشها كما يجب أن يفعلها البالغون من العمر 36 عامًا ، ومن
ناحية أخرى فهي رائعة
وزير